l'armé - josh mon rocher qui va prendre
froid alors moi je vais toujours dit
alors n'être pas d'accord oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est bonjour
je serais sympa cette nouvelle mise en
scène la moco restiez oui non j'ai
toujours dit pour moi est que gill et
mathieu
[Rires]
mois avec gill et mathieu jean michel
maire c'est le meilleur chroniqueur de
tpm pays les très bons sur la forme il
est très très drôle c'est une nuance nay
peur pour moi ils apprennent du fonds il
a été grand reporter donc pour moi il a
entièrement sa place et oui à chaque
fois qu'il revient de temps en temps je
me dis c'est domenech je vous dit rien
soit pas la plus souvent il est dans
l'air tous très gentils et vouloir que
tout le monde soit dans l'émission à
manger des clubs place alors oui mais
voilà l'autre chose c'est neuf places
pourquoi vous engagez un chroniqueur
toutes les quatre minutes 16 on est
soixante et un nouveaux chroniqueurs
fait plus tard démission
[Applaudissements]
alors on attend tous les soirs un biais
sa mère comme deco amis
faux
c'est
[Applaudissements]
merci
vous l'avez remarqué chez moi à 19h29 il
y à des dépréciations
il ya des gens qui craquent il ya des
gens malades
il ya des gens qui ont dans leur cas
qu'il ya des gens qui craquent c'est la
vie c'est mpc sa as nous avons défendu
sur la feuille de match à 21h heure vous
nous aurez de la fête
non
ok je m'en dire à ses besoins de voir
des nouveautés parfois cunego
[Rires]